I think like many people who work in
worse sanfur to film and television and
came south now they have an interest in
music whether that's actually their
conventionally trained or playing bands
or like myself was more interested in
electronic music and recording mixing
music run a small 8-track music studio
with a friend of mine did local bands
south of Cardiff was bubble based in
South Wales the area and then sort of
accidentally got involved in recording
location recording a low-budget film and
really didn't know what I was doing and
sort of realized that I would enjoy the
process enjoy working on the film but I
felt I needed to go and learn how to do
it properly so I applied and got into
the national film school sound course
and so we did their sort of sound
editing in sound recording so that was
sort of how I fell into but I'd sort of
had an interest in film sound as well I
don't think I'd ever thought of it as a
career until I started as I said it
almost by accident fortuitously working
on one I think the I remember sort of
seeing him raised a head David Lynch's
first feature film and being sort of
very overwhelmed and sort of impressed
and sort of why the use of sound that
sound design in that film which is quite
revolutionary at the time and realizing
that what I was interested in musically
a20 use extensive electronic music could
be applied to film which I hadn't quite
realize that putting that to that point
more interesting filmmakers understand
that sound sound design as part of their
storytelling arsenal and that we can
create use sound to create the emotional
world of the film because sound works in
a different level different area of the
brain two pictures in images and what's
a more perhaps more primitive
fundamental area which is why it's often
so effective in horror films and
thrillers and so but also we can be used
apart from you know I think people most
generally think of sound and sound
design in terms of genre films and said
horror films or sci-fi films but I think
it can be used in very subtle ways
in other types of films generally we are
hired before the during pre-production
process but with filmmakers I work with
regularly then that can be at first
initial draft or beyond concept stage
sometimes the composer can be more
involved than not sometimes a lot of the
time and can put sound people or sound
designers and composers don't talk very
much and then the music sort of arrives
within the mix during the mix but other
times there is it is a more
collaborative proton going process I
think it is best it is when more people
are talking to each other that's the
most rewarding I think creatively
creatively productive way of working
some design just I just plays the
important part in establishing the mood
and tone but less is more I'm slightly
yes I've heard I've almost started
hearing that phrase when I first started
working on it and I'm never quite sure
what it means and I think suppose that
sometimes that things are stripped down
and there but sometimes that's not the
case and certainly the case where you
never really hear there are points in
the film where we apply silence virtual
sounds in room tones of the house the
mother's house is quiet deliberately so
contrasting with immediately with the
streets of New York when Joe goes
outside and the traffic is actually on
that mixed unnaturally learn out it is I
mean that was a big debating point it's
actually not just loud city
it's an overwhelmingly loud city and so
I think what I would say is dynamics is
what it's about it's about I think about
film at its best is equivalent to a yes
might sound a little pretentious a
symphony in terms of you have loud bits
in quieter bits and that the two things
reinforce each other of course it
depends on the nature of the film a film
like ratcatcher Lin's first film or
Hunger Steve might have worked with on
Steve McQueen is based around virtual
silence and then the sounds activity
reaction coming out of the silence with
heightened use of heightened foley ADR
breaths in case of hunger
and and selectively I think selectivity
is a word I'd use
rather multi layering I think if David
Lynch Eraserhead is multi-layered and
constantly oppressive they're in a film
robert bresson and man escapes its use
of selective sound is the polar opposite
but both equally powerful so depends on
the nature of the production
understanding what the film requires so
to answer your question less is not
always more it depends what's required
we were hired for the imposter by Bart
Layton's first film because they the
filmmakers didn't want to a traditional
documentary sounds in they wanted a
sound team which myself and my colleague
Andres Turk who mixed the film and also
did the diluting of both films that we
came from a fiction background and even
though the imposter was ops tends to be
a documentary if they want the the brief
was to make it more like a thriller
genre film there was very close
collaboration between myself and Johnny
green woods musically took graham
Stewart actually is also his producer
and engineer as well so Grahame because
of Johnny's demands and scheduling which
is more he's not it wasn't really
available in Iran so basically during my
post but at some post-production for you
were never here so the person I dealt
with was Graham who sort of worked on
the music and edited the music and we
both drew up we sat down together and
went through the film and drew up a
spotting list a sheet of Google Doc that
was a breakdown of the film of what was
happening with darl or eight dialogue
ADR Foley sound design and music what
was happening where and and I was able
to play Graham what I would you know the
sound design as it existed at that time
and then sort of them we could discussed
ideas about what cues would fits where
because Johnny doesn't always write to
picture they sort of like it sort of
like a lot of contemporary composers
their writing mood pieces based around
the mood of the
or perhaps the scene but not necessarily
strictly scoring to all the hit points
as a traditional film composer would
doom American animals as the second film
worked on with Bart Leighton the
director the first one was the imposter
as you say it's a mixture of document
and rectangles and mixture of
documentary and fiction but less so than
the first early imposter which was
really could be classified as a pure
document was a documentary with
reconstruction I think with American
animals what happened was the
reconstruction merged into sort of
fiction drama and I think it's
considered as a fiction film rather than
a documentary but the documentary
elements are the interviews with the
real people behind the story I think
within that film it was treated in
American animals we treated a sound as a
conventional genre film it was a heist
it's a high part heist movie buddy
and sort of young man's buddy movie part
the Latin sort of a unfolding disaster
which you can it's an unfolding car
crash I think it's been described as the
film has been we can see what's going to
be happening cuz we know what the I
think what's interesting is the you know
what's happened in the film right from
the beginning you know they're not going
to get away with it because of obviously
the interviews of the real characters
have plainly been - been to prison I
think that the advice I would give
myself is to have confidence in my own
abilities I think I was very uncertain
insecure a lot of people coming out of
educational establishments or trying to
get into the industry the first time
feel there's going to be really
difficult road but I think if it's
you're good communicator and you
couldn't talk to people and I think also
that one of the big skills is is a it's
a it is a clear Chevrolet's of people's
business and so you need to be able to
get on with people and relate to people
and relate to your the team you're
working with in the film because you're
working for I think you need to
understand film and understand story and
a study film and I think you can just
it's not the the plug in the technology
changes and certainly has changed over
the period process a period of time I've
been involved in film sound and I think
it's really understanding why you're
doing what you're doing
and if you're not necessarily the most
technically able because there's lots of
people who can impress you with their
technical knowledge but correct they
have no understanding or empathy with
the emotional journey on the story as
far as sort of reading material or
courses or now online material for
learning about sound film sound design
is there's a little note there's quite a
lot available certainly a lot available
online now a lot of its and certainly
literature and online material deals
with technical processes use of plugins
use of software what's available and
that's all important because one has to
learn your craft but I think that there
are other websites as well and books
michelle xian french writer is a very
interesting author his books are well
worth seeking out and talks at a deeper
level about sound concepts it can be a
little bit daunting because it's written
from the is a French intellectuals point
of view so it can be a bit perhaps the
little the concepts can be a sort of a
bit complicated at times but it's well
worth reading I think there are plenty
of courses available I think that
undergraduate courses in this country
are Bournemouth certainly very well
thought of and Ravensbourne
amongst others and then postgraduate
wise the National Film School our Shah
would give a plug for because I'm a
graduate off there and have do teach
there I'm visiting tutor there it's
probably because of its sheer sort of
resources and equipment and also used
most of the most important things you
get a chance to work with other film
makers so I think that's it's also
important perhaps if you're not going to
college though there are other ways of
working with film workshops and I think
actually it's working really to work
with other people and actually watching
films I think that's the main thing is
just watching films and television with
with it and sort of getting an
understanding of film language
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]